pokemon legends arceus has been such a
refreshing take on the pokemon formula
dramatically changing what we've gotten
used to over the last 25 years
introducing new elements for players to
explore i've beaten the game and am well
into the end game now and i've compiled
together some interesting things that
i've noticed during my playtime if you
have any easter eggs or anything notable
that i missed drop them in the comments
below i might even grab them and make a
part 2 of this video a quick note that
there will be spoilers from the story so
keep that in mind here are 12 things you
didn't know about pokemon legends arceus
be sure to sub to the channel and like
this video while you're at it now let's
dive in
as you progress through the campaign and
save the hasuy region's various noble
pokemon from their mysterious frenzy
you'll also come across wardens that
teach you how to use these mounts these
mounts have a variety of benefits with
the key bonus being that you'll be able
to access areas that were previously out
of reach you'll start off with the word
ear and then eventually in ursulina
basket lesion sneezler and finally a
braviary
one cool thing that you can do though is
you can swap these mounts on the fly
without having to get on and off each
time you can simply press the d-pad to
change your mount at any given moment
and if you were already on a mount and
happen to go into the water for example
you'll immediately swap being in the air
or in free fall or even near a cliff
side will also give you a button prompt
to mount the right pokemon for the
terrain
you know sometimes pokemon break out of
their pokeballs that is a sad fact of
life however there is a tight window of
time where you can immediately throw
another pokeball for a second chance
catch
the best way to secure this chance is by
keeping a pokeball at the ready as soon
as the pokemon breaks free you can toss
a ball at it before it even notices you
and either enrages or
flees animation for the pokeball is
slightly different from the og games
historically the pokeball is supposed to
shake and wobble before being caught
usually three times throughout most of
the past games in legends arceus the
pokeball will dramatically pop up in the
air and emit steam clouds
you can get a quick gauge on the catch
rate and probability of the wild pokemon
being caught based on the amount of
steam high probability catches look like
only one cloud of steam is emitted and
the ball only gives a little pop in the
air while alpha pokemon and other more
difficult to catch pokemon will emit up
to three clouds of steam with the
pokeball launching super high up
now suppose you need a nice break from
the countless quests cutscenes and all
the paris trying to murder you
in that case you can hang out with your
pokemon in the overworld but not near
wild pokemon just find a bit of free
space and throw your pokemon to spawn
out and then stay within the vicinity of
them you can even interact with them and
speak with them it's also not limited to
just one pokemon either toss out your
entire team and watch them all engage
with each other you can even have your
pokemon interact with those nearby npcs
such as the warm pool or cascune and
jubilife throw out a dust talks and see
what it does
now some areas such as the alabaster
icelands will have dynamic weather like
hail or snow storms other areas may have
rain if you need to change the weather
all you have to do is simply rest at
your camp weather can be a boon if you
have pokemon moves that match the type
but it can also be detrimental if you're
using ineffective moves for example my
typhlosion was having trouble using
effective fire moves since the area had
a lot of rain but a quick camp rest
until the rain subsided and now we're
back to our regular strength
now this is an important one because
historically any pokemon involved in a
battle would get xp once the opposing
pokemon fainted this means you would
normally get xp up to 6 times per battle
however that's all been streamlined now
and your entire team will receive a
cumulative xp total at the end of an
encounter most of your encounters will
be with wild pokemon so this is not an
issue still on the rare occasion that
you encounter a noble or battle of
trainer be sure to keep in mind that if
any of your pokemon are fainted by the
end they will not receive any xp
regardless of their contributions
throughout the battle
being poisoned paralyzed or asleep used
to be a major annoyance after a battle
ended but now all status effects are
temporary whether you use an agile
normal or strong move a status effect
will have a certain number of turns
before it wears out
using a status move again will refresh
the counter you can also overwrite
certain status effects for example
causing a burnt enemy to now be
paralyzed
maybe you're using stealth rock and you
realize wait this works more like
whirlpool or firespin from the older
games or maybe you notice that the base
power and accuracy of certain moves are
slightly different well you're right
pokemon moves have had a dramatic rework
in legends arceus for example you might
not know that pulse moves like dark
pulse dragon pulse and water pulse now
have a 100 accuracy rate and any kind of
slashing move has a high crit rate
regardless of what it is this means that
dragon claw and x scissor now benefit
from a higher crit rate chance that used
to be exclusive to a move like slash
most of these reworks make sense since
there is no pvp battling in legends
arceus some of these changes are really
awesome though self-destruct for example
no longer completely faints your pokemon
instead it deals closer to like 80
percent of self-damage and huge
destructive moves like giga impact or
hyper beam no longer require a recharge
either which is wild so you can just
unleash the move back to back moves like
rollout or outrage don't lock you into
using the same move but instead now
state that your pokemon is simply
fixated on the move meaning that using
it again will gain a damage boost but
it's not mandatory not only are the
moves some of the biggest changes with
lots of hidden traits but their
animations look sick as hell too
at some point near the end of the main
campaign you will have a choice to be
accompanied by either the diamond or
pearl clan leader as you embark on the
red chain main request depending on who
you pick that will decide which
legendary pokemon you catch first and
which you will have to battle with bombs
in a noble style boss battle in my
playthrough i picked the pearl clan and
i came face to face with palkia
eventually going back to dialga later in
the story to see that dialga actually
adopted a cool origin style form during
the noble boss battle
so if you prefer to battle palkia in
that climactic battle at the end instead
and end up using the origin ball on it
make sure that you pick the diamond clan
when given the option this way palkia
comes later regardless of who you pick
you will have the option to catch both
legendaries a first for diamond and
pearl
by default your wifi connection will be
off when playing legend's arceus be sure
to turn it on that way other players can
return your lost satchels which are
important in netting mp points
you can use the mp points later to buy
evolution stones or evolution items such
as thunderstones reaper cloths metal
coats and so much more
as you go through the game's story
you'll unlock several different
locations such as the coronet highlands
or the cobalt coastland if you save the
game and fully back out and exit you'll
be greeted by a curated menu screen the
next time you log in the classic pokemon
legends arceus logo will appear on the
right with an image on the left of the
last section of the region that your
character saved its progress in
alright this is a fun one there is a
photo booth in jubalife where you can go
in and pose for the camera even putting
on this like old timey filter lens to
give it a old-fashioned and historical
look talk to the photographer and change
your poser expression you can even get
your pokemon out there too to pose with
you and hilariously you can have your
pokemon played dead it looks pretty damn
funny simply select the option for your
pokemon as you set up the photo and
enjoy
now trust me when i say there are a lot
more things on this list that i'm saving
up for a part 2. so if you want to see
more and are interested in pokemon
legends arceus please let me know sound
off with anything you've picked up on
during your play time and i'll throw
them in a future list video meanwhile do
me a solid and check out some of our
other pokemon guides and reviews and for
everything else be sure to stay with
gamespot until next time
[Music]
you